[BLANK_AUDIO]
Let's go ahead and begin today's webinar.
I'd like to introduce Paul Marca.
He is the executive director from the
Stanford Center for
Professional Development.
Welcome Paul.
>> Thank you Stacy,
I appreciate it and it's my pleasure to be
here with you today.
The Stanford Center for
Professional Development has been
delivering education to people in
the world of work for many, many years
since 1969, and online since 1997.
We're particularly pleased to be hosting
this webinar and also this
course offered by Professor Jo Boaler,
Mathematics Education here at Stanford.
And I have to tell you that I have a
secret mission as to why I'm so
excited about this course.
I have three small children, twins 12
years old and
a ten year old who desperately need to
like math.
And currently the, the level of
instruction is not good, nor inspiring.
Dr. Jo Boaler is Professor of Mathematics
Education here at Stanford University, and
it's our pleasure to welcome her and the
collaboration also
with the Vice Provost for Online Learning
here at Stanford University.
We, they have built the course so we are
extending the course out to as
many of those of you who can attend both
this session and
we're now queuing up another offer in
August slated for, offer number two.
Dr. Boaler is here at Stanford in the
Graduate School of Education and
also co-founder of YouCubed, whose mission
it is to harness the power of
new technologies to transform mathematics
education in the US and
beyond, in order to give teachers and
parents the resources and
ideas they need to inspire and excite
students about mathematics.
Again, why I'm so interested in this
webinar and the course.
She's also editor of the research
commentary section of
the General Research in Mathematics
Education.
And an analyst for the PISA testing in the
OECD, and really the author and
creator of the first MOOC on mathematics
in teaching and learning.
In times past, she has been the Marie
Curie professor of mathematics education
in England, a mathematics teacher in the
London comprehensive schools and
a lecturer and researcher at King's
College, London.
Her PhD won a national award for education
and
research in the UK, and her books, a
number of books,
particularly her latest, What's Math Got
to Do With It in 2009,
and The Elephant in the Classroom in 2010,
published by Souvenir Press in the UK.
Both aim to increase public understanding
of the importance of
good mathematics teaching.
She serves as an adviser to several
Silicon Valley companies,
including the one she has nurtured,
YouCubed, and has been a frequent
presenter to the White House in girls and
STEM issues.
So with that, I want to turn the floor
over to Professor Jo Boaler.
Jo, welcome.
>> Thank you, Paul.
Hello everybody.
Good afternoon, good evening, good
morning.
[LAUGH] Whatever time we're in, so first
of all,
I'd just like to say hello and welcome.
Some of you, I know, will have probably
taken my online course last summer, and
it's really good to see you again, if
that's the case.
Some of you may not have been and so I've
pitched this really today to,
some of it will be review for those of you
who took it, some of it will be new.
And if you didn't take it, a lot of it
will be new, I guess, but it's been a very
interesting year since the online course
that I taught last summer.
I've been working very closely in one
particular school district, Vista Unified,
and I shared some of that.
I launched YouCubed, a nonprofit site at
the end of my online course, because so
many people wanted to keep getting the
ideas, and
I'll tell you all about that later.
I was in the White House last week, which
was very exciting.
I've just finished the online MOOC course
for
students, which I'll show you a little bit
later.
And as Paul mentioned, I'll be working
with PISA.
So most, I'm really excited and
happy that we're re-releasing the parent
and teacher course.
And later on, I'll show you some of the
sort of impact of that,
which was really great.
I've also been in lots of parent meetings
and
what I want to do is share a video with
you soon that I'm making to help for
parents who are sort of not understanding
the math changes that are needed.
And I wanted to mention as well, I've made
a handout that every reference I give in
this session and all of the links I give
are on that handout, so
you can go to the website later if you
want.
So I want to start actually with a
question to you, and
I think it would really help me in talking
to you if I know who did actually
take the online course last summer.
So perhaps you could answer the polls.
And if you took any of it, please say yes
and if you didn't take any of it, say no.
And then, also I have a question about
whether you're a,
what, a teacher or a parent or working
some other way.
So if you could answer that poll now, that
would be great.
Thank you.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So I think we're gonna get the answers to
the polls pretty immediately,
so we can all have a look at those I
think.
Let's have a look, all right, so, pretty,
almost evenly split.
So, about a third of the people, did take
the online class, that was interesting and
really evenly split amongst the different
levels of school.
So great, I love that, we have all
different grade levels and a few, and
some parents as well.
So, I'm gonna begin,
I thought I'd share with you a picture I
took in the White House last week.
So you're probably thinking now,
did I really take that photograph in the
White House?
I did really take that photograph in the
White House,
but it was cheating a little bit cuz the
president was in China at the time.
And that's actually a photograph of a
photograph in the White House.
But I think it's a really nice photo, so I
thought I'd share that with you.
So anyway I'm gonna begin today by,
briefly, just for
five minutes, going through sort of a
basic idea behind the changes that I
think we need to make which for some of
you will be review,
and then after that I'm going to get into
my favorite teaching strategies for you.
So the big idea that I've been talking a
lot about is this thing that we
suffer from in the US, which I describe to
people is the elephant in the classroom.
And you know, the expression the elephant
in the room, which refers to an idea that
everybody's thinking about but nobody
talks about, and I argue that there's
a big elephant standing in most math
classes in the US and in other countries.
And that is the idea that only some kids
can be good at math.
Teachers believe that, parents believe it,
and students believe it.
And that single idea is the root of a lot
of the underachievement in the US,
and I think as math teachers we have to
deal with this myth that's out there.
That being good at math is some kind of a
gift, and
that some people are naturally good at
math and some are not.
So we have decades now of research, really
solid research,
that shows that is completely false.
You're not born with a math gift.
Nobody's born with that, and everybody in
fact can achieve at high levels in school,
it's to do with the experiences people
have from birth.
And it's also really important how kids
think about this,
the ideas they have about their own
ability and their own potential.
So you probably know Carol Dweck released
a book which is
a New York Times best seller, in which she
summarized her research from a number of
years which shows that people have one of
two mindsets.
So if you have a growth mindset, you
believe that the more work you do,
the smarter you get.
If you have a fixed mindset, you believe
that you're either smart or you're not,
and it turns out that about half of kids
have a fixed mindset in mathematics and
that mindset really harms their learning.
So we also know that these different
mindsets go along with
different behaviors.
So kids with a growth mindset are more
persistent.
They're willing to learn from mistakes,
they're very determined to keep going and
they're encouraged by each other's
success.
Kids with a fixed mindset are those you
probably know in your classroom,
you give them some challenging math work
to do, and
they'll immediately say, I can't do this,
I need help.
We know that fixed mindset thinking
affects students from
across the student spectrum, and
in fact, high achieving girls are some of
the worst hit by fixed mindset beliefs.
And we also know that praise is really
important in
giving these different mindsets and the
way that many kids in the US have a fixed
mindset is because those parents in the US
often praise kids for being smart.
So when they do something good, we say
you're really smart and what we now know
kids process about this, is that first
they think, oh, good I'm really smart but
when they fail and they will, later, they
think, oh, I'm not so smart.
And it starts to set up this fixed ideas,
in Carol's latest research they
found that the praise given to babies
between the age of 0 and
3 predicts their mindset five years later.
So very important around the way we speak
to kids.
And this graph just shows you kids,
students who've given
a survey at the beginning of seventh
grade, to see which mindset they had.
And the line that goes on the bottom is
the kids with a fixed mindset, and you
know, they just follow kids over the next
year or two, to look at their achievement.
And those are the growth mindsets of the
ones that go onwards and upwards.
So we also know that mindset is very
important implications for equity.
Mindset interventions have the greatest
impact on, for
students of color and for girls.
And as I said, fixed mindset thinking is
much more prevalent among high
achieving girls, and in fact the reason I
was at the White House was I was,
reporting to the Council on Women and
Girls about girls in STEM.
And I talked about some of this, the
importance of mindset for girls, and
the paper I handed out at The White House
is on
YouCubed and you can see that in the
handout.
So, as was mentioned, I've been working
with a PISA team over the last few months,
which is really exciting, you probably
know the PISA team give
international math surveys every four
years.
But they also collect a lot of data on
students' ideas about math and themselves.
And so this data hasn't really been
released a lot yet,
cuz we're, we're writing some thing up.
But, it turns out that the mindset kids
have are hugely important and
also the way they approach math is really
important as we all know.
And in fact the kids who say that they
memorize, so
when they approach math they, their, their
approach is to try and
remember lots of things, are the lowest
achieving kids in the world.
The kids who come into math saying they're
thinking about the big
ideas are the highest achievers, and what
we can see from this graph is
the huge difference for the kids with a
fixed and a growth mindset.
So the kids with a growth mindset are the
highest achieving kids, this is
from 13 million 15 year olds, and those
with the highest achievement in the world
are those with the growth mindset and that
use these good strategies.
The sort of strategies that I discussed in
highlights in the teacher course.
So, I'm gonna talk about five key
strategies today, and they fall around
these four big things that are all really
important to teachers around how we group,
how we assess and grade, the tasks we give
and what we do with mistakes.
And it's my view that the two biggest
changes we need to make in US
mathematics education, the first one is we
have to get students believing that
they can achieve at the highest levels of
mathematics, which many don't now.
And then we also have to engage them
actively with mathematics.
And we know that when we get kids problem
solving, talking about
mathematics reasoning through problems,
they achieve at higher levels, so
they're really important and particularly
the role of mathematical discussions.
So we know that, you know, contrary to
common belief that the best way to
study math is to be alone with a book.
We know that when kids talk about math,
it gives them access to a deeper level of
understanding.
But there's another reason to have kids
talk about math, and something that I'm
talking to parents about when they're
opposing the common core.
So what I'm finding is a lot of parents,
particularly of
high achieving kids are saying, why should
my child explain their methods?
They can get the work right, why do they
have to explain their methods?
And what I say to them is explaining
methods, is what in mathematical language
we would call reasoning, is really the
core of what mathematics is.
So when a scientist proves something, they
look at it in a number of different cases.
But for mathematicians, they actually
reason their way through to proof and
it's the core, as a discipline.
And I wrote an article about that, which
appeared in The Atlantic last year.
And if you have parents who are needing to
understand both the and, teachers too,
the way to change the way we think about
kids, and how to get rid of the,
the stereotypes, also the importance of
reasoning.
And you can find that article, and the
link is in the handout.
So, I'm gonna start off by talking about
grouping.
We know that discussion is really
important,
discussion in whole class discussions,
discussion in small group discussions,
but it's often derailed, as teachers know,
through unequal participation.
So what can happen often in group work is
one student will do all the work,
another one will be left out, somebody
else chooses to check out,
and that isn't the way good group work
works.
So, I'm curious and I'll put this in a
poll in a minute, how many of you know
about this, but an approach to group work
that I've found to be associated with high
achievements as have other researchers, is
one called complex instruction.
So, complex instruction starts on the
basis that you have to
make group work equal.
And you have to counter status differences
to do that.
And they do it.
Then you can do this in any subject at any
grade level by giving the students roles,
by teaching a broader, what I would call
multi-dimensional mathematics, by giving,
and by giving different messages about who
can achieve.
So the approach was designed by Rachel
Lotan and Liz Cohen, and
if you want to read more about it, there's
a great book on it, Designing Groupwork.
The yellow one has been out for some years
and is available now.
They've actually just re-released the book
but if you want
the re-released version it's coming out in
July and that's on your sheet.
But anyway, now I wanna come up to my
first strategy,
which is something I've really come to
love over the past year.
So it's, this is really new.
But I I'll tell you about that, but before
I do, I just am curious about whether any
of you have used the approach of complex
instruction at any time.
So, there's a poll now coming up,
have you ever used the strategy of complex
instruction when grouping kids.
So I'll just wait and after a little
while, I'll take a glance at that.
[NOISE]
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay, so I think we're gonna see okay, so
we have 16% of people who have used
it at some time, 62% have not used it, and
22% we don't know.
So if you would like to, to learn more
about this approach,
then those books and also articles on
YouCubed will help you with that.
But there's something particular they do
inside complex instruction, and
I'm gonna teach you.
Before I do that some other things we
talked about in the course was the way we
assess and grade kids.
Obviously, the way kids get feedback on
their work hugely impacts their mindset.
And one of the things we talk about in the
online course is how replacing grades
with diagnostic comments is really a
positive thing for students' engagement.
So, we tend to grade a lot in the US.
In other countries, kids get the grade at
the end of the year.
And what we know from studies is that when
teachers stop grading all together and
give diagnostic comment,
telling kids what they need to do to
improve achievement really goes up.
So, but I know as well and I, you know,
from all the work I do with teachers,
that particularly teachers in the US feel
that their hands are tied.
And that they have to be grading a lot
because the school
administration requires it, the parents
require it, districts require it.
So, one of the things that I recommend for
them is to switch the grading.
So, instead of grading always being on,
sort of of how many answers are correct,
actually grade on the participation you
want to see in the classroom.
And once you start grading on that, kids
participation drastically improves.
So, this leads me to my first strategy,
which I'm really loving at the moment.
So, this is something called a
participation quiz, and
those of you who know complex instruction
may know this strategy.
So, I taught this to the teachers I work
within Vista school district, and
they did the participation quiz the first
day with a group.
And they tell me by the time the groups
met for
the second time, it has transformed the
way kids work in groups.
So, the way it works is, students work in
a group on some math work, and
they are literally graded, the group is
graded, at the end of the lesson for
their participation in the group work.
So, the teachers are actually looking for
how they participate.
Are they leaning in and talking to each
other?
Are they asking good questions?
Are they working equally?
So, I'm gonna take you through how to run
a participation quiz.
It would be much better if we could watch
videos and talk about this in a PD
session, but I'm hoping this will help to
just try it once and see what happens.
So, this is how you run one.
You just choose an ordinary day of group
work, where kids are working on math
tasks together, and then you tell kids
they're gonna get a grade for
how they work in the group at the end of
the lesson.
And then, it's very important, you show
students what you're looking for
in their group work.
So, the example I'm gonna show you, the
teachers share with students.
We're looking for these kind of
interactions, and
we're looking for this kind of
mathematical work.
Now, then you either get a piece of paper
or some teachers do it on the board
publicly, on, on a, whatever form of
display, into sections for each group.
So, if you have 32 students, and working
groups of four,
which complex instruction recommends, you
might have eight sections.
And as students are working on their
groups, teachers circulate the room,
just writing down comments inside the, the
boxes for each group.
How well they're working, any good
questions that come up, and
then at the end of the lesson, they assign
each group a grade.
So the teachers I work with, I'm just
pulling their slides that they've used for
a complex, for a participation quiz.
Just to give you an idea, but they show to
the students before these.
So, this is the mathematical slide.
There's a lot on here.
I'm not sure I would use as many,
particularly for
younger kids you might wanna highlight two
things.
So, this shows you a full range of things,
the sort of things you could put up here.
But, so they say we want you to be
recognizing and describing patterns.
Justifying thinking using multiple
representations.
Making connections between different
approaches and representations.
Using words, arrows, numbers, and color
coding to communicate ideas clearly,
explain ideas clearly to team members and
the teacher.
Ask questions to understand the thinking
of other team members,
ask questions that push the group to go
deeper, and organize a presentation so
the people outside the group can
understand your group's thinking.
And, sort of, the mantra of complex
instruction that the teachers use
with it is this message to kids.
No one is good at all of these things, but
everyone is good at something.
And you need all of your group members to
be successful.
So, these are the kind of mathematical
things they're looking for and
then the teachers had very concrete things
group behavior.
We're looking for you to be leaning in and
working the middle of the table.
So, a nice strategy for group work is a
sort of tip really is
to only have one work piece of paper, cuz
if kids have their own paper,
they are very likely to pull off to the
side and work on it.
So, one piece of, one task paper, are they
leaning in and
working in the middle of the table, is it
equal air time are they sticking together,
are they listening to each other, are they
asking each other lots of questions, and
then following the team roles?
So, the teacher, I might have a sheet,
something like this, and walk around
making notes on a clipboard or as I said,
I might have it at the front of the room.
And I'm just gonna share with you an
example of one teacher's notes at
the end of a participation quiz.
So, you can see they're both, they've
graded the groups but
also at some points they've just said
great discussion, working well together,
building on each other's ideas.
Sometimes there's a question written down
that they, is a quote from the kids.
Can anyone see a different way, you can
see the see the bottom left hand
group weren't working so well together
talking about clothes, off task.
So, what happened with the teachers that I
work with in Vista school districts is
they tried a participation quiz one day,
and
they told the, the tea, the kids, we're
gonna be grading you in a group work.
They went down making notes.
And I guess the, the kids didn't really
pay much pay much attention to that.
And at the end of the day, they gave the
grades and talked about it.
So, what they said was the next time they
did group work,
the very next time, the kids' interactions
in the groups had massively improved.
So, they're really loving using this as a
group work strategy.
So, this a quick overview, but I'm curious
and I put in another poll here to see.
My question is, do you think you would try
a participation quiz?
One thing I can do is put up more detailed
instructions on
YouCubed if you would like.
So, maybe I'll just stop for a minute
while you can fill that question out.
Do, do you think we, you would try one of
these?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right, so I think we have the results
and we'll just wait a little while,
and we'll all have a look at what you
might think about participation quizzes.
All right, great, so, a lot of people are
interested in trying.
That's great so I'd be really interested
if you try it to hear what happens.
So you could email me.
I have a Twitter account.
I'd love to know, if you try these out,
what happens over the next sort of times
doing group work.
So my next thing I want to talk about a
little bit is classroom math tasks.
So, in the teacher online course, we spend
quite a bit of time on tasks and
thinking about what makes a really good
task for students.
I argue that it's very hard to have a
growth mindset in math when all you work
on in math class is a series of short
closed question that you
really get right or wrong.
So, those kinda question don't convey to
kids that math is about learning.
And in fact, we know that a lot of
students actually don't think that
they're in math class to learn.
They think that they're there to perform.
And they'll tell you that when they go
into math class,
what's important is to get questions
right.
So, they're not so oriented around
learning as much as performance.
And this really came home to me recently
when a colleague of mine, Rachel Lambert,
told me her six-year old son came home one
day, and said he hadn't liked math class.
And she said, why, you know, what
happened?
And he said, math is too much answer time
and not enough learning time.
So, that's a really perceptive comment
from a six year old, but
it, you know, you can see how kids get
this impression.
That they go into math class and they're
answering questions.
So, what I do in my work with teachers,
and we talk about the teaching course is,
tasks need to give students the space
inside them to learn something.
If a task really,
is just answering a question, that doesn't
really have space for learning.
So, I shared this framework we've
developed for the Growth Mindset Tasks.
They need to focus on learning and
have opportunities to learn something
inside them.
So to do this, the main thing is to open
up Math Tasks.
And you can open them in different ways.
You can have a task where you ask kids
this, how they see it, and
I'll show you an example in a minute.
You can have tasks with multiple entry
points, tasks that value different
pathways and strategies, tasks that focus
on sense making rather then an answer.
And I'll, we'll look at a little example.
So this example comes from a wonderful
teacher, Kathy Humphries, and
it's actually in a book of video cases of
her teaching her 7th grade class.
So, it's called, the book's called
Connecting Mathematical Ideas, but
one divided by two-thirds is,
could totally be a closed one answer
questions that students just answer.
But she opens this up by focusing on sense
making.
She asked them for the answer and
then asks the students how to make sense
of their answer with a representation.
She you ask them for the answer and
then asks the students how to make sense
of their answer with a representation.
So, what you get from that,
is there are very, there were many
different ways of seeing the problem and
students have different methods and
different representations.
So the, many of the kids in the class got
the answer six.
You know, do so maybe, two and three comes
out with six, and, but
then they really struggled to make sense
of that.
So, Cathy uses this in the classroom.
I really like this and it's really good
for the common core.
And it comes from a book by some English
authors actually,
where they talk about telling students as
a three-stage process,
really three levels or three standards of
a convincing argument.
Now, kids need to be making convincing
arguments with the new your common core.
And what they say, is that the lowest
standard is when you convince yourself.
We're usually pretty easy to convince
ourselves.
The next level up is when you convince a
friend, and
the third level up is when you convince a
skeptic.
Actually, in the book they say convince an
enemy,
and Kathy changed it to a skeptic, I
think.
anyway, she has asked the kids to be
skeptics, and
I did this, actually just the past week
with a group of teachers.
It was great.
And I said okay, really got to be
skeptics.
You've got, got to push any answer you
get,
any reasoning to make sure it completely
makes sense to you.
Be very skeptical.
How do you know that?
How do we, kids love being a skeptic.
You can get them all to be skeptics with
each other and
they take on that role really readily.
But it's also really helpful in pushing
other students to convince and
reason, so very mathematical things, too.
So, I wanted to tell you about a wonderful
task that helps kids be more convincing.
And in fact, I used this task just last
week with the role of a skeptic,
where some people had to convince others
and the others were skeptics.
So, this isn't the whole task, but the
whole task is on YouCubed and
it comes from Mark Driscoll, and
it's a book called Fostering Geometric
Thinking, and it's a paper folding task.
This is one of my favorites, and I think
this is great for lots of age levels.
So they, I'm only showing you a little
extract of the whole task, but
they start with a square piece of paper,
and they have to do all
these different constructions, and just
one of them's up here.
Construct another square.
With half of the area that is oriented
differently than the one you
constructed in four, with the whole list
question.
Explain how you know it has half of the
area.
So this is a great task.
Kids actually have to make this, and fold
their square, and
then they have to be really convincing
that they know that this is a.
Square so what you see as they do this.
They push to be very precise to be very
mathematical.
To use the right words.
Particularly if you have other people
being skeptics.
So I love that task on YouTube there's a
high school unit.
So theres there units on YouTube at the
moment.
One for elementary on for middle on for
high.
The high school one, actually is one we
wrote at Stanford, and
it's over 100 pages of great activities.
And this paper folding activity is one of
them, it's on page 87.
So if you wanna go to that task you can
buy
the book from Heinemann in the links
there, and it's, it's a great book.
Or you can get the task in that way.
So an example of something that I want to
share with you now comes from a five week
algebra class.
That I actually, taught with graduate
students in summer school.
So it was a summer school, seven and
eighth grade kids, who were mainly under
achieving.
And we, our goal
in teaching the class was to teach algebra
as a problem solving tool.
And we drew from different places,
Rathore, Ruth Parker, Mark Driscoll.
Some English schemes, but one of the
things we did was we kept
all of the tasks open and we actually got
amazing participation from the kids.
My book, What's Math Got To Do With It?
Describes what happened in the summer
school in more detail in the tasks.
But we basically gave them a lot of
algebraic pattern tasks.
They hadn't learned algebra and they
learned algebra through that and
did really well in algebra afterwards.
But, and we kept the task open.
So I wanted to share with one strength.
One issue that teachers have is kids
always at work at different levels.
They are different achievement levels.
They work at different speeds.
One thing I like to do in my own teaching
with kids.
Is always to have a strategy up my sleeve.
Which is to get any kids who finish to
either extend the tasks their given or or
ask a new question.
So like this has happened a lot in summer
school and
this is one example we gave the kids.
This task right and there are two ways to
get this task.
Find the total number of blocks in a
hundred block high stair,
staircase is a kind of traditional way of
asking that question.
The way I like to ask it and
you may have seen before, is asking people
how the shape grows visually.
And from there they get to the hundred
block question,
but much more conceptually.
But anyway.
We asked when kids finished we just said
okay you now over to you you come up
with your own question.
One of the boys who got all F's in math
class came up with this lovely extension.
Which is much harder conceptually at where
they were looking at staircases and
all of the kids started doing this so.
My strategy really around this is whenever
you're working with short math questions,
with long math questions.
Great strategy with kids is when they get
to the end just say to them: now
over to you.
You write the question and try and make it
a hard question.
And then have kids give their questions to
each other.
It involves kids in a much deeper way.
It helps them with the mathematics.
It helps them in all sorts of ways, so I
really like that strategy.
But so, generally we know that when maths
tasks are more open,
opened up for different ways, seeing,
different pathways.
Different representations, the
opportunities for learning and
for developing a growth mindset are
increased.
So a couple other things to share just
before we finish.
Not gonna say much about speed,
other than we do know that math should not
be associated with speed.
And the article you see there just came
out in NCTM's journal, and
it's also downloadable on youcubed, about
the damage caused by timed tests.
That is the dimension of that.
But what I wanted to finish on the last
couple of strategies is I shared in,
in the teacher class.
And we spend a bit of time discussing how
I teach these classes for
teaching math for a growth mindset.
And Carol Dweck came into the first one
and
said something which shocked all the math
teachers.
Which was every time a student makes a
mistake in math a synapse fires.
And actually we have new research evidence
just from the past year that
shows that when kids make a mistake in
math, brain growth occurs.
Fire, electric stimulants fire in their
brain,
But when they get work correct, no brain
growth happens.
And they don't have to go back and correct
the mistake which a lot of people think,
it's really the point of struggle that
causes that brain growth.
So this has huge implications for us I
think as math teachers.
It means that we really want students
making mistakes.
Mistakes, or when their brains are growing
the most.
But they need to feel safe in the
environment to do that and
know that mistakes are valued.
Really great for teachers just to start
the year saying I love mistakes.
Mistakes are when you're brains grow.
I want to see mistakes,
you'd be amazed how much that puts kids at
ease mathematically.
So here's my source strategy.
This actually came from a teacher in the
online class so in the mistake session.
I ask people to design a sort of new way
of handling mistakes in the classroom.
And I'd love to hear who the teacher was
who suggested this.
So if you're listening, feel free to email
me.
But one of the teachers in the class
submitted her idea.
And she said this.
She said at the start of classes now she
gets kids to crumple up a piece of paper.
And throw it at the board with the
feelings they have when they make
a mistake.
And then she gets them to unfold the
paper.
And draw a little brain on it.
And then just draw over and color all the
lines from the crumpled up paper.
And that represents all the synaptic
firing of making mistake.
And she, she gets kids to keep that to
remind them.
Another thing I loved comes from one of
the teachers in Vista, Kim Hallowell.
Who took from the course all the messages
that came from the course,
about the value of mistakes and other
things.
And she asked kids to, to design a picture
of their own brains.
And you can see there all, they were
told about the parts of the brain that
sort of see in black and white and color.
And so they each designed their own brain,
and they put their favorite message on it.
Cause it's a beautiful visual and
you can see some of the different messages
they chose, the kids chose.
Easy is a waste of time, I don't know this
yet,
embrace the struggle, I can grow my math
brain.
Lots of things.
So, couple of things about the future,
just to finish off.
I will be uploading on YouTube within the
next month.
We just have funding for YouTube and so
we're just finally putting lots of new
stuff up there.
And a video for parents explaining why
high achievers need to be in.
Classrooms with others and and working on
these ideas and other things so
look out for that.
So beyond my class which some of you took
is now rereleased by Stanford.
It actually was amazing last summer,
it really surpassed all my expectations
40,000 people registered.
And at the end 92% of people said they
were very or
extremely satisfied with the course.
95% said they would change their teaching
as a result of the course,
always helping their own kids.
And they did that.
I had thousands of emails from people
great, you know,
detailing the changes they've made and how
it had changed their students.
So, the course is up again, Standford is
charging for it.
At this point, it $125 it, you can take it
and
get a cetifi, a sort of certificate for
your school.
They, schools, I hope, will pay for this,
or districts.
And we know that some districts will pay
for teachers, or
give them salary advancements.
So if you want to take the course it's
open now, you can go up and register.
Also we're, we're releasing a student
MOOC.
So these are things to get the ideas
straight to students.
Six short 15 minute sessions designed to
improve students relationships with math.
Give them a growth mindset.
Features my undergrads helped me present
it.
I'll show you a little bit.
And that's designed for students of any
age.
The details of that are on the handout
too.
So in fact I'm just gonna show you a
little minute clip from these students who
also we have.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
More details, so more, more details for
that are on the handout.
And then youcubed is the non-profit site I
started last year just to keep
these ideas up for teachers.
Has a number, and parents.
Has a number of sections on it.
A section for parents, for teachers.
There are different units on it.
Some videos.
Details of the MOOCs.
If you sign up with your email, for that
you'll get newsletters.
And there's gonna be a new to,
really different full of ideas site in the
next month.
So, if you're signed up with your account
through school, and
you wanna get new ideas over the summer.
You might wanna sign up with a personal
email.
But, if you go to the bottom of the site,
it just asks you just to give your name,
and to do a math problem, that's so they
know you're not an alien.
Somebody tweeted me and said they were
glad it wasn't timed.
It's not timed, but if you fill in your
email,
you get all those great things that are
going to come up in the summer.
And then we have a little clip of the
teacher course too to show you.
So you can get an idea of the sort of
things we work on in the teacher course.
We're gonna show you that now
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[NOISE].
All right, so, we've had some questions
come in.
We'll just spend the last few moments on
answering a few questions.
so, Ken asked a really great question
about alternate electricty.
The question is, how do we don't have
timed tests?
Do we develop alternate electricity?
Well, we know that timed tests actually
don't encourage automaticity.
The fast kids stay fast, the slow kids
stay slow.
And that article on YouTube does show talk
about other ways of
developing mental math and automaticity.
So definitely go to that as a resource for
that.
Derrick has the number of people that
finished the teaching moog.
Actually it was, 40 percent of people that
got right to the end.
And I think the people who actually
engaged was higher than that.
Cause many teachers it ended just before
the school year starts,
just after the school year starts.
And so I know lots of people only got
through about half of it, so
now's the chance to get through the other
half, but.
Yes, so but still, great, great
participation rates.
Much higher than other MOOCs.
I'm looking at other questions now.
So, oh, I'm not sure how to pronounce
this.
Bla, blawana, perhaps, asked how the
grouping and
strategy be adapted to very small classes
or multiple grade level classes.
So I think conference instruction is
really great,
the more diverse the class is.
Actually we, we know it works well when
classes are very different,
the kids very different.
Better than when they were all high or all
achieving low levels.
So great if it's multi aged, it works in
small classes too.
Somebody said should you jump from having
students in rows to doing a four
person group.
Would it be easier to start with pairs of
students?
And can I do the participation quizzes in
pairs?
I think the participation quiz would be
hard, I suppose you could try it.
I mean, I'm all for trying things in the
classroom.
And, and seeing what happens and learning
from them.
You probably can get good participation
happening with two.
But ideally, I would go to four people
groups and
they come with an instruction book.
Really gives you some tasks to start with
that really need for
four people so I, I think you can go from
roles of four in a group.
It's amazing how well, how good students
are, actually, at.
Engaging in groups.
Particularly if they have set roles.
How do you convince Linda's asking how do
you
convince to take the time support
discourse and reasoning.
When your focused on how many standards
and
the depth to which they must teach those
standards in the typical school year?
So, discourse and reasoning are a big part
of the common core standards.
And you probably know if you've tried some
of the new tests that are coming out.
They also assess discourse and
reasoning, and kids can no longer be
successful choosing A, B, C, or D.
They have to explain their methods, so.
It's very important for their achievement.
It's also extremely mathematical.
It is the future that kids need.
We know that the biggest growing job in
the US is somebody who is a data analyst.
All of the new companies in the US have a
large amount of data.
And people need to be able to ask
questions of the data and
reason through different presentations
they give so that other people can access.
It's a very important thing and,
this goes in reasoning, the cherry on the
cake really.
Give, students better access to
understanding and
help them achieve, At high levels.
What's so, the question that ultimately to
be without speed drills I've
mentioned going to that paper to see some.
The other thing I recommend is, if you
want kids to practice some math.
There's nothing wrong with practicing math
but it's important that I,
I recommend they do that on engaging apps
and games.
We have one developed at Stanford called
Was it Trouble,
which is a really nice app.
Notion Math is really nice.
There are all sorts, there are lots of bad
math action games out there, actually.
And so I try and recommend ones.
In fact the, in the teacher course,
there's a section on which apps and math
app games are good.
But that's a good way to practice, and
it's much more engaging for kids.
So, somebody says can you talk about math.
Linda, can you talk about math
disabilities and does it have a fix,
does having a fixed mind have a role in
that?
Absolutely it has a role in that.
And I think a lot of kids, there are kids
who have particular special needs.
And then there are kids who've just been
traumatized by math.
And actually it's hard.
A lots of the time just separate those
kids.
Most kids who are achieving, at low levels
do have a fixed mindset who.
And so working on mindset with those kids
has a huge impact.
And it has the biggest impact on those
kids so definitely What are the dates
of the summer teacher course and will we
have access to notes for today's webinar?
So, the teacher course is open for
registration now.
it's, the class will officially open on
June 16th, and stay open.
And what we are looking to doing is having
the first cohort.
So, open from June 16th, stays open till
mid September.
And then maybe, a second registration, if
people want to take
it, late August and go through sort of
later in the fall, that one.
But, at the moment it's open, you can
register now.
And do so, somebody, Andrea, can you speak
about when you're the only person in
your school that believes all this.
How do you keep your spirits up when the
structure doesn't value
what you feel is critical?
Yeah, I absolutely feel you, Andrea that's
a really hard situation to be in.
Always great to have colleagues.
What's wonderful about new technological
age we
live in is you can find those colleagues.
And have those colleagues, through that
connections, technologically.
YouCubed is gonna start having a larger
teacher community on it,
so I would recommend signing up there.
To teach a course, the teacher's stay
together.
so, I guess we've run out of time.
But thanks very much for
joining, joining me, and yeah we, we'll
send out notes from-
>> Joe, thank you very much for a
wonderful webinar and
a more terrific course.
Your commitment comes through loud and
clear.
And I believe that, ev,
everyone will benefit from this, both
parents, teacher at various levels.
Thank you all for joining us, and we wish
you a good day wherever you are!